any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable
all right everybody it is a pleasure
today to welcome
dr delilah gates we've had on
mother daughter combinations we had on
andrea
and sasha sagan mother daughter duo
and now i can say we've had on father
daughter duo
jim gates and now dr delilah gates as
of about three weeks ago as we're
speaking here in may
delilah a brilliant scientist became
a phd at harvard university
and is moving in the fall of princeton
university
not far away and she is going to tell us
about the fascinating universe
of black holes and their electromagnetic
signatures
and ways that we could possibly observe
them we're going to go deep we're going
to start
broad but you and me into the impossible
audience are some of the deepest and
brightest
in the known universe so delilah should
not fear to go as deep as possible and
you're in for a treat
because uh she is one of the foremost
exponents proponents
and experts in the world of the universe
really
of these mysterious magical mystifying
objects known as black holes
so you're going to see a real kind of
insight into research
at the forefront of astrophysics and so
now i turn it over
to this brilliant colleague delilah
gates take it away delilah
wow thank you so much for having me um
this is that was such a
magnificent introduction i feel very
humbled
of to have such things said about me so
um
as you mentioned i just recently
defended my phd
at harvard and my thesis was on
um observational signatures of
black holes which like planets can be
spinning
and in particular we know that there's
ligo which can
observe in the gravitational waves but
we also can get electromagnetic
signatures that is light
uh from the matter that's accreting onto
the black hole and so that really is the
realm of which i study
um and so let me start broad with a
question with a couple questions
um namely um we are
lucky now to have this image of m87
from um
[Music]
the event horizon telescope
collaboration which is the first
image of a black hole uh
near horizon region created from
observational data
um and it's a very blurry image but it's
a
remarkable feat of technology um because
of the angular resolution
um that is needed to create such an
image it's
very tiny on the sky uh because of how
far away this black
hole is from us and so um but if you
were to look at an image like
of a black hole um and we so we now have
one from data
in the close uh near horizon region but
we know how to simulate them
if we are looking at images of black
hole of course
you might wonder how do i know this
image is a black hole
or in particular more detailed how do i
know
that what i'm observing is a black hole
and what are the distinguishing pr um
characteristics of it how fast is it
rotating how massive is it
um if it's rotating we can be viewing it
off the spin axis at a various angle
and so these are kind of the questions i
try to dive into
uh with my work um
so um to start let me
uh kind of go broad so um
early on uh the idea of a black hole was
actually
perhaps first proposed in uh way back in
1783 which is uh perhaps surprising but
it came from the simple thought
experiment of philosopher john mitchell
when he asked what if you had a star
that was so
dense that its gravitational pull was
such that the escape velocity from the
black hole
was the speed of light or greater and
this obviously today
invokes in us the idea of the event
horizon but the idea kind of died out we
didn't have the mathematical
machinery we didn't think about
space-time curvature yet so it wasn't
until
einstein in 1915 when he gave us general
relativity
that we were really able to make headway
in black holes
and studying them mathematically so
it turns out um if you describe a black
hole mathematically
you describe the shape of space-time
which has to have an event horizon
somewhere
um and there are different solutions to
the einstein's equations
that have event horizons in them um
einstein never thought someone would be
able to
describe the shape of a space time that
would solve his equations of general
relativity the einstein's equations but
it turned out very quickly the first one
came along
from schwarzschild and this was just a
non-spinning
uh non-electrically charged black hole
uh soon after um discovered by several
people
over uh the next couple years discovered
and rediscovered was the case of a
spinning of a non-spinning black hole
that's charged
uh breaking spherical symmetry just down
to axia symmetry was hard like i said
black holes can spin
we see planets spin all the time stars
and so just like that black holes
themselves can spin
um and it wasn't until 1963 that kerr
gave us
the idea of the spinning black hole that
was non-charged then it was
um not too difficult to jump uh where
newman gave us the
the solution that describes the spinning
and charged black hole
the reason it's perhaps nice to think of
this spinning
charged black hole is because this is
the most general
axi-symmetric uh black hole
we can describe that is uh
asymptotically flat
we reason we want asymptotic flatness is
because that means far away from the
black hole space looks flat
and so it would be relevant to our
universe um
but it turns out charge mass and spin
are the three things that could
in principle describe a black hole but
we actually
uh expect that uh real world black holes
aren't aren't electrically charged and
this is because they don't exist by
themselves in
uh in a vacuum in the way that they do
in the idealized solutions to einstein's
equations they actually have matter
accreting onto them
and so they could easily neutralize
themselves just by
absorbing charges particles of the
opposite charge to themselves
um
so this tells you a little bit about uh
the history of black holes and why
curb black holes are specifically the
spinning case non-charged
or what we want to study when we think
about the astrophysical black holes that
we're going to observe
or that we're starting to be able to
observe in the near horizon region
thanks to technology like the event
horizon telescope
so this solution let me just flash it
for those who care
but don't be intimidated by the
equations please this is just uh the
mathematical description of the
shape of space time where we have this
asymptotically flat
kind of funnel shape and it's spinning
about
about a rotational axis and so the two
things that describe it
are its mass and its angular momentum
and so this seems to say that black
holes are
deceptively um
simple they it seemed you would seem to
think that all black holes at least in
general relativity so not considering
quantum gravity
are just described by two parameters how
fast they're spinning and how massive
they are
it must be perhaps then easy to take an
image of a black hole
and then understand uh
or or mine from features in the
in the image what the spin and mass of
the black hole are
so this goes to then the idea of
simulating black holes
and so the first ever simulated image of
a black hole came from luminaire
in 1979 and in this case it's a
uh black hole with a thin accretion disk
around it that's non-spinning so a short
shell black hole um
and one of the things that we notice is
we get um kind of this dark depression
in the center
we have this bright ring around it etc
and this um
um was done uh back in 79 but
today uh we do them a little more
sophisticatedly
using uh general relativistic
magnetohydrodynamical models
when you see the images or you see these
simulations or even the data from the
event horizon telescope
are we um are we visualizing here
the black hole the event horizon or
what's called the light
shadow i've heard there are differences
between these different concepts
this is a really good question so let me
go to my next slide
um because it is a sharper image and it
might be a little nicer to look at
so here um on the left we have uh
the some um an image from one of the
observing days
that the event horizon telescope
collected data from
the new horizon region the light around
m87 star
the black hole in the center of the
galaxy m87 and here's a
magneto a general relativistic
magnetohydrodynamical model
and so the question is what exactly are
we seeing so there are a couple things
the first thing is um we
generally a generic feature we get in
these images
of black holes is this real is this
bright ring and the reason for this
bright ring
is actually particularly interesting so
um
when we think about black holes uh what
and we solve the equations that tell us
how
light travels between two points around
the black hole
it turns out every point in the
geometry is in fact connected to
an observer if you take two points
between where the light is emitted
in an observer uh there are
infinitely many paths that actually
connect the observer
to the um
to the to the source point and so this
actually implies that you get
um an infinite number of images of
the source emission around the black
hole and in fact
um what we
can see is the reason for this is there
are these bound orbits around the
around the black hole um these bound
orbits
exist in a region outside the event
horizon um
in what we now call the photon shell and
so they're a particular set of radii
around the black hole where we can get
photons on these kinds of bound orbits
like shown here um
in fact this is an example from an uh
um an applet that you can play with
online at leo stein's website due to
symmetry.com
i suggest everyone go play with it it's
very fun and you can look at
the shapes of the bound orbits that uh
photons could travel around a black hole
and so we have this region in which the
black hole or the light around the black
hole can orbit in
perfectly circular orbits but it turns
out these orbits are unstable
uh so this means if we were to perturb
them just slightly
um the the light the photons would
travel
many times around the black hole before
either spiraling into the black hole
or going off to infinity
and you can actually parameterize
the number of times the the light
the photon wraps around the black hole
before reaching its destination
in half orbits and it is in fact this
that leads to
uh the multiple images you get of the
black hole
one of the equations describing uh the
motion of the black hole describes
where its theta position and its our
position the radius and the
the angle theta and so here is an
example you have
a point um on the
in the disc and you have an observer you
can have light that comes from it
directly
uh with an extra half orbit around the
black hole completed or with two
and technically you get an infinite
tower but in particular
you can map exactly where kind of a
locust in the sky of where these points
want to
pile up in it so the the more and more
highly lens wrapping around the black
hole multiple times
images of the black hole actually tend
to stack up together
um kind of on top of one another almost
to give you kind of this bright ring we
see
um so but this is this is one this is
one thing that is
apparent in general relativity but this
doesn't quite explain the image we have
from m87
star at this resolution here's an
example of just taking the grmhd model
and blurring it
and you see it looks really similar to
the image we have
uh from the observed data which is good
but we're not necessarily sure from this
resolution
that what we're seeing are the
de-magnified
uh images that are of the same source
being stacked on top of each other
being blurred a lot of the emission is
of course just the direct light as well
you can kind of see this kind of
background uh uh very red
looking in this image um just general
that's just the direct image of the
source emission
and then we get images stacked on top
that get more and more demagnified and
more and more focused on this
um position in the sky um
and so it's not necessarily apparent
from the
data we have now at the um v87 whether
we've
actually gotten a lot of flux from
the more highly lensed images of the
source emission
so there's still more work to be done so
what are we seeing we're kind of seeing
we're probably seeing something like
this that's blurred but we haven't
quite been able to pull out um
enough features to exactly say that we
know we've captured
a lot of light from the lensed images of
the the more highly
uh the images from the sources that wrap
around multiple times
except for just the direct um but
we are um you know if we
if we do assume that it comes from such
a model like this we can
uh based on just blurring a model like
this or several models like this
that could match or look close to m87
ones
do you can't spring
um even in splurge form to get an
estimate of what the mass must be
and so but but in particular the details
of how these
the light stacks up should also give you
information say about the spin of the
black hole
and we haven't we definitely haven't
done enough
um we don't have a high enough
resolution yet
to be able to definitely say we've we've
seen these higher lens images and thus
could could say constrain the spin of
this black hole
um another thing is you might notice
there's kind of this dark depression in
the center
um and you might think that this uh
is also something that if we had a
sharper image would be
easy to say what this is a map of um but
it's actually not quite simple
that simple uh the exact position of
that inner dark um kind of depression
compared to the bright ring
uh it does depend um heavily on your
uh details of the astrophysics
where the matter is around the black
hole how much it's emitting
is it mostly on is the matter that's
emitting the light mostly
radially plunging into the black hole or
is it spinning around the black hole a
lot very circularized
so um even this inner shadow um
its details are are somewhat of an
astrophysical question
not just a general relativistic can you
say something about the
challenge as a um to solve these
equations in gr we're
usually presented by um you know as
advanced undergraduates when i
teach cosmology i might expose them
if i do to the uh you know friedman
equations how we derive them
from gr or how in principle you can get
them in the newtonian limit
from the einstein equations maybe as
a teaser i'll show them at the learning
graduate school
the einstein equations very simplified
form
you're talking about solving these and
magneto hydrodynamics
these are very challenging equations to
solve can you talk about how you
actually solve these on a computer like
how do you um constructively do it i'm
an experimentalist so
i never solve these equations even even
using paper and pencil but first of all
what makes them so challenging
and then you know how can a computer
even approach solving these
and provide images like the simulations
that you work on
so i actually myself don't do general
relativistic magneto hydrodynamical
models i
generally work very much in the realm of
of
looking at kind of pen and paper
stripped down
toy models doing exact calculations as
analytically as possible
so i don't generally myself do um
general relativistic magneto
hydrodynamics but i can tell you how it
works so
the first things to to think about there
is
the modeling the accretion and that's
really where the gr
mhd is king this has to do with taking
the matter and modeling as a
as a plasma that has turbulence and all
these things
and magnetic fields that's wrapping
around the black hole
and emitting light but then of course
you know you can say
i have this disc and it emits light but
the question is where does it end up
the question of where it ends up and
appears to an observer
is actually
[Music]
not um is actually something that's
really nice in the case of the current
geometry
it turns out um so in general let me
talk just a moment about
how we describe um an image of a black
hole like the one i show
the ones i've showed versus um what the
light is actually doing
so in general you can think of you know
um
a black hole or some other massive
object that will lens particles as they
travel around it and
the observer will collect them from the
light that hits it from different angles
um to mimic what we see since we're used
to living in a flat space
what we do is we do this idea of
thinking just
i would assume the way my brain puts
images together
that i project the light straight back
onto a plane and this kind of mimics
what we see
um it turns out to describe precisely
the paths
around the black hole that light takes
in the case of the kerr geometry
is actually um very
it's simple compared to um a lot of uh
generic cases
it and by what i mean by simple is that
the
motion of the particle actually depends
on some specific
um conserved quantities in the space
time there's the
um the energy of the particle there's
its angular momentum
um and then it also has one more um
conserved quantity called the carter
constant which it
doesn't have as nice a um
physically intuitive description as
angular momentum or energy
but um in the schwarzschild case it's
you can think of it as being related to
not just
the angular momentum around the spin
axis but the the total angular momentum
the particle has um
and so in the case of the the current
geometry
um it turns out it's quite simple to say
exactly what the particles do like i
said
um their energy depends on these
specific equations
but it turns out further that it's com
the equations are completely integral
which means that you can write a set of
integral equations that use elliptic
functions
that relate any source position to any
other
um to any other point um observer
position
and so um these have been known for a
long time and you can throw
then you can just take these integral
equations and throw them
onto a computer so if your light is
emitted from a wrap from near the black
hole
uh um from this disc that you've modeled
um with grm hd you can then just ray
trace so you can just
um use you just know you know exactly
where your observer is so you know the
kind of paths
that the light will take between the
observer and the source
um and you can just really integrate um
numerically it turns out you can
actually do it completely analytically
but sometimes it's
that's a little challenging and um
time consuming so you can do it
numerically or analytically
and you can just literally trace the
paths that the light's gonna take oh wow
in the case of how this is done in
practice let me also mention
um you might say if i just look at the
source
and then trace all the paths that the
light can take a lot of the light is not
going to hit my observer
right if i look at a point near the disc
the light's just shining out
from all directions from a single source
and only some of them are going to go
hit my observer
so in practice what we actually do is
the opposite we
we trace from the observer to different
points in the disk
um along the geodesic um or the path
that the light takes
um and as we so we just look at our
image
uh our image screen on the like do the
example let me just pull back up
this guy so we might say okay let me
pick a point
on my screen here um
or here i'm gonna say how bright should
this point be based on my
um emission model so i say um
this point it arrives the light arrives
at me from this angle
i know then that what that means exactly
what its angular momentum
and carter constant will be and it's i
could know its energy
and so then i i shoot i trace back along
the path
from the observer into the geometry and
every time
uh along the path that i cross matter i
i
load more brightness onto my pixel and
so
this is known as um radiative transfer
the radiative transfer equations you can
also include details of not just adding
light
um to make the pixel even brighter every
time you cross matter if the disc has
some
absorptivity you can also subtract some
of the brightness depending on
where it crosses the disc as well
and so that's how we build these models
after we have
um described the emission using
um the general relativistic magneto
hydrodynamics
okay great
so in particular though um describing
general relativity magneto hydrodynamics
is complicated and it
um and like i said you know there are
some things common about these issues
in images like the bright rings from all
these different
emission models but there's also some
things
uh that vary like for instance exactly
where that dark depression is
um you have things in common you
definitely get a bright ring you
definitely get a dark
depression but whereas the edge of the
dark depression etc
is kind of complicated and so my
work particularly focuses on um
thinking about the things that are
similar in the image all the images uh
of a black hole you could think oh it's
hopeless how will i ever know
what black hole i'm describing um if i
can change the spin and still get
very similar images if i can change the
astrophysics and still get very similar
images
but the fact that there are these
commonalities between the images
actually suggests kind of a separation
of the different types of features in
the black hole images you can look at
the features that are universal
like the fact that you will have a
bright ring and these are mostly
driven by the general relativity or the
fact that you get multiple images
stacked on top of each other that's
driven by the general relativity and
then the features that vary with the
creation model
um really are driven by the astrophysics
so in
in my work i try to really target the
features that are universal
and use these to pick out
um ways we could mine information from
the images
from the observations of black holes
without having to be aware
of what the astrophysics is also and
i've noticed in your papers you you
focus also on
external black holes am i pronouncing
that right
extremal extreme good this is exactly
what i wanted to say next
okay great yeah i was hoping you could
explain to me what that is
cause i read it in your papers that i
don't i'm not 100
since we're going to pick out um
since we want to pick out the the
features that really are driven by the
general relativity we want to think
about the ways
that the space time of a black hole is
unique one i already mentioned for you
was the fact that you have these bound
orbits and then can get multiple images
of your source
and the other thing is another property
that i like to exploit
is for the case of the high spin black
hole
um and this is what we call an extremal
black hole
their their high spin black holes are
just mean um we're taking the
spin of the black hole up to um
its maximum so let me back up for just a
moment and flash
uh the the metric um for you once more
so like i said this black holes uh the
details this
only are described by its mass and its
spin um
angular momentum about around its spin
axis
uh in particular we use this parameter a
to describe that so if the angular
momentum is j
um we have this spin parameter a um that
is just
um equal to uh
the angular momentum around the spin
axis if we multiply it by m
um in particular one of the things we
notice about
uh the space time is it has an event
horizon which is
whose location also depends on those two
parameters the spin and the angular
momentum
but in fact there's a bound on how fast
black holes can spin
cur black holes can spin this is called
the curvebound
um and the reason for this is if you
spin the black hole any faster than this
you would not have an event horizon
and then you would have a naked
singularity we think that's probably
unphysical
uh there's the cosmic censorship
conjecture but in addition to that
um we also think that physical processes
probably prohibit us from taking a black
hole that starts
below the curb and ever actually getting
exactly
to its maximum spin um
and there have been attempts to quantify
exactly based on physical processes what
that bound would be the most famous of
which is the
thorn bound which is
nine 0.998 percent of maximum spin um
it's not actually sure if this is the
right bound
um there are some assumptions like a
thin disk model and what not
uh made by uh to derive that bound but
it does seem that we probably can't spin
black holes all the way
up to this bound but it does look like
from a lot of experimental evidence that
we can spin them pretty close to this
bound
and that a lot of black holes are
probably
very rapidly spinning and so this is a
motivation for why we care about this
particular property for
high spin black holes or extremal or
near-extreme will black holes extremal
just means
at its maximum at its extreme value
and so in particular what happens when
we spin the black hole very fast
is it turns out the the kind of the the
the funnel part of the geometry gets
really really elongated
um and in fact in the limit that you go
actually all the way to the maximum spin
it
technically would get infinitely long um
but an interesting thing that happens
as we um if we zoom into the horizon is
it turns out
this this region that is this
long throat region of the black hole
actually has more symmetries
than just the general curve geometry so
the
the kergeometry is stationary which
means it doesn't change in time
and it's actually symmetrical it means
you can rotate it
about it the spin axis the black hole
and it will look exactly the same
turns out there's if for the region
close
to the horizon of the black hole that is
described by this
in principle infinitely long or
elongating neck as we spin the black
hole up
or elongating throat of this geometry is
there are two more symmetries um that
develop
um and it turns out um
that we can use the exploit these
symmetries
um to for the case of high spin black
holes
or or um to say something about what
would be some observational
signatures specific to um black holes
that are spinning
very close to the to the maximum
um one of the interesting symmetries one
is very hard to describe but the other
one
is is called a dilation um
and it has to it basically tells you
that the physics at one radius
in this uh this this throat part of the
geometry where you're close to the black
hole
it looks almost like a perfect cylinder
um
in this region it turns out that the
physics at one uh radius
along this uh this cylinder should be
the same at the as the physics along
another
part of the cylinder so this actually um
kind of has interesting implications
and it's in and of itself this kind of
dilation
symmetry that you have and so
um from understanding those two things
understanding
the bound orbits and understanding these
extra symmetries that develop
near the horizon of a rapidly spinning
black hole
um these two unique properties
of the curve geometry allow me to look
for
or pinpoint signatures that would show
up in
being by being imprinted on the the
light that we observe from around the
black hole
um to say things independent
of most of the astrophysical details
what are some
hallmarks telling us we're looking at um
um
high spin black holes for reference uh
for reference
how um how close to extremo are the
black holes that ligo typically finds
like
in terms of spin or mass or or the eht
you know tens of million solar mass
black holes
how could you say what their spins i
mean i know we don't have great limits
so far but um do we we have any ideas no
or is that the um that is it's actually
it's actually
um so in the case of of m87
we don't have a necessarily a great spin
estimate uh there are some papers
claiming it might be as high as 98
percent of externality
um but this is it's very unclear um and
in fact this is
you know one of the motivating features
for
upgrades to the event horizon telescope
or to extending our
um event horizon telescope-like
observations to include
a um space
a telescope in space um
the reason for this is um i'm not an
expert in this but
we use interferometry to to
um image these black holes um so really
what we
observe is the fourier transform of the
image like the one i showed you that
blurred image that blurry image of the
near horizon region that was collected
from data but we really we really
observe this in kind of fourier space
and um the details of this depend on of
course the size of basically your
satellite dish but instead of a single
satellite dish what we really do is use
um two different points right now on the
earth's surface basically turning the
whole
um diameter almost of the earth into the
length of the satellite dish and so by
we can use different length dishes to
get different resolution to increase our
resolution
um or different lengths between our two
base baselines
different like baselines and so um this
is a motivation
the fact that um
the fact that we if we get higher
resolution
of the new horizon region of this of
this black hole like m87 or our own
um galactic center uh sagittarius a star
if we can get higher resolution and
really tease out details like
the fact that you would have the
repeated images on top of themselves
uh and where it would be located um
or conversely like i said there are
there are these multiple images but of
course there's a time delay
between like if you've got a flare um
there's a time delay between the
first image of the flare as seen by the
observer and the second image that comes
from the photons that wrap around the
black hole more and so if you can also
think about the time delay
um and and making correlations between
the time delays um if you had higher
resolution you would be able to tease
out
information about what exactly better
what the spin of
m87 is i'm 87 so this is part of a big
big piece of motivation for extending
the ht
um or the next generation eht
so um i guess i can um
as a final thing say exactly what are
some of the
observational signatures i've studied i
won't uh go into
a great detail about them but maybe i'll
flash them on the screen
um so um one of the ones is
gonna particularly depend a lot on the
fact that the black hole is
a high spin black hole and we're gonna
what we do is we
look at the polarization recently the
eht released polarization data
from an m87 star which is amazing and
wonderful it
gives us a hint about what the magnetic
fields should be like around the
um black hole and so in the case of
um a high spin black hole one of our
proposals was
we notice in simulations that
once you've time averaged an image
that the often the the image that you
see from the light around the black hole
has the same symmetries
as the space time in the case of curve
black holes this means once we've time
averaged
the light around the black hole looks
very
um axi-symmetric and so we said what if
we assume that this inheriting of the
symmetries
um is true for all space-time symmetries
in the case of the high-spin black holes
light from near the horizon then
should have imparted on it these extra
symmetries
that the near horizon geometry has when
the black hole is maximally or near
maximally spinning
and so if we constrain um what the
polarization should be
when it's emitted near the black hole
with these symmetries and then use our
geodesic equations to transport it to a
far away observer
what might we see and so in particular
we might see something like this um so
um this this outer red curve that i'm
showing you is what's known as
uh the critical curve um you can think
of this curve
as being where in the sky
exactly the bound orbits would map to
um the the photons traveling on those
bound orbits would map to
um in the case of a really easy way to
think about it is if you were to
backlight a black hole
um a black hole was just by itself
nothing
spinning around it or creating onto it
but you backlit it what silhouette would
it cast
and in particular it would cast a shadow
that would have a dark region
on the interior and then be bright all
outside of it of course this is not a
physical thing because black holes
aren't backlit and they can have
sources anywhere around them but that's
kind of intuitively what this critical
curve is and
it turns out if we were to consider all
the light from this near horizon region
of these macules being black holes we'd
get these
um polarization patterns if they were
constrained by those
near horizon symmetries um that only
would fill up this region
that's inside the critical curve or
would be the dark region if we were to
backlight the black hole
and so the polarization in these plots
is shown in black and the different
colors the blue
yellow and green just corresponds to how
many times the light wrapped around the
black hole before reaching the observer
so it's not
you wouldn't actually see any of the
colors like that it's just uh for our
own kind of um
um image uh um and in k
in particular in the case of something
like m87 star
uh it would it would look something like
this
um another um observable
uh that i've thought about is what is
if you had a a disc around a black hole
that was
uh spinning what is the maximum uh
blue shift that the light that you
observe from around that black hole
would be
in particular
we can think of of a
black hole say with a very thin disc for
a toy model we did we did a thin disc
that's a
in the equatorial plane of the black
hole uh we can think about all the light
around the black hole being emitted from
orbiters from from particles that are
orbiting the black hole on stable
circular orbits
um and then we can ask what of all the
light that was emitted
what would how what would be the most
blue shift of the light we could get and
in fact
this is really relevant because this is
already a method used
uh to constrain the spin of black holes
here i've just shown
uh just the direct image of a black
hole's disc um
where we are we've colored the disc by
the blue shift
or redshift um that you would observe
and this is relevant because this is
actually already used as a method to
constrain the spin of black holes you
can think of
if you know what the line emission
say from an element in the disc is going
to be
we think they tend to have a lot of iron
so we could target a specific frequency
in
iron's emission spectrum say the
k alpha iron line which is very
prominent and we can ask
we can look at how the whole single
emission
gets brought in some of the broadening
some of it will some of the light will
be blue shifted
some of it will be redshifted depending
on where it's emitted in the disk
because of the motion
of the particle in the disk relative to
the observer and then
also there's also an overall redshifting
from the gravitational
uh uh redshift as well uh and but it
turns out the gravitational redshift is
not
so big that you never get light blue
shifted relative to
the frequency it is emitted at in its
own rest frame
um it turns out very close to the black
hole the
the particles orbiting the black hole
are moving at such relativistic speeds
that even they'll impart enough blue
shift with their motion that the overall
frequency you would observe would
actually be blue shifted relative to the
the emission so it's never
gravitationally redshifted
right um some of it will be and you
actually get kind of broadened
profiles of a mission um that looks
something kind of like this
but in particular we were just asking
about the most blue edge
these are some models from a code called
reline
which takes the model i described before
thin disk orbiters on
the emitters orbiting on stable circular
orbits in the equatorial plane
um and you see of course the whole iron
line
uh k alpha that's it's marked here um in
here
um that you get these brought in
profiles but these profiles vary
dramatically depending on what angle
you're observing from and the spin of
the black hole
so we were really trying to see how much
of the information was just carried by
um the blue most blue shifted
edge and it turns out um you can
actually
kind of analytically describe what
happens for all different spin cases
um analytically or semi-analytically and
so
this is uh kind of what we get this
right here is blown up here this box is
blown here we have in the different
colors the different spins
the black is an approximation that fits
for when you're viewing
at angles close to the pole of close to
the spin axis
and then in the high spin case it turns
out we have also this orange
dashed line i can go into more details
if people care but this is the
theoretical limit of exactly what the
what the
highest blue shift you could get is and
you need to understand to analytically
calculate this you need to understand
the
new horizon geometry as you spin the
black hole up um
but basically what we find is that the
spin of the
the maximum blue shift of the black hole
for look for
if you're viewing close to the pole it
gives you very good um information about
what angle you're viewing the black hole
from it doesn't tell you about the spin
but for the if you're if you're
observing closer to the equator of the
black hole say like we are
to our own galactic center then it tells
you a lot of information of being able
to constrain
the angle which you're viewing the black
hole from and the spin and if you
already have some
some angular information about what
angle we're viewing the black hole from
say a jet
then it really becomes a tighter
constraint just on the spin
so these are kind of these are a couple
of the observational signatures
that we've been able to characterize
and i guess i will mention the last one
the last one that i thought think about
have thought about for my thesis
isn't as tangible as the other two
because
it just talks about light from these
from a disc around a black hole that's
again made of these circular equatorial
orbiters but the case is now we have
light that could fall into the black
hole or just escape to infinity but we
don't
particularly say where at infinity so
this isn't quite a real observable in
that
we can't put a bunch of um detectors all
around a black hole yet we don't have
that kind of technology
um but but i use the term observable
loosely and i mean it definitely talks
about light that reaches the faraway
observer
and doesn't get captured by the black
hole and in this case
in particular we can we can describe two
um two features we can say if light is
um traveling on one of these circular
stable
uh orbits around uh if a particle if a
massive particle that's emitting light
is on one of these stable circular
orbiters
what percent of all the emission
it releases if it's just isotropically
emitting escapes to infinity versus
being captured and it turns out even
down
to the innermost stable circular orbit
um even in the case of the most
rapidly spinning black holes more than
50 of the light will always escape
from these kinds of orbiters which
seems surprising because you you say oh
as you spin the black hole up the
innermost stable circular orbit gets
really close to the horizon
you would think a lot of its light would
get captured but it's the case that more
than 50
will always escape and then also we
could say
um we could say of the light that
escapes the celestial sphere
um what would for all the observers on
the celestial sphere what would the
profile of the
light look like in terms of redshift um
and in particular there's a nice
um image of what the
black hole does to the flux profile in
general you would say the flux would
look linear but
the light that gets capped by the black
hole is these little
bites that are literally taken out of
the the flux so the black hole
imprints these bites on the flux curve
so these are the um kind of the
um the kinds of things that i think
about
uh when i think about black holes is
really trying to
tease out information about um
tease that information that will let us
say what
the black hole is how fast is it
spinning how massive is it what angle
are we viewing it from
without having to you know do these
expansive searches where we compare it
to a lot of astrophysical
models because we don't know what's
actually going on uh near
near a single black hole that we could
observe in the sky one day
that's brilliant thank you so much
delance is
any excellent advanced technology is
indistinguishable